[MUSIC PLAYING]
DINO CHIESA: Dino here.
In the prior videos
in this series,
we learned the how and why of
API proxies and API products.
In this video, we'll learn
about the API portal.
The Apigee Edge developer
portal is the best way
to connect developers
who use APIs to the APIs
you've created.
It includes an elegant
web experience,
clear interactive
API documentation,
and a self-service way to
get credentials or keys.
However delightful
your APIs are,
if developers cannot
easily get access to them,
if they cannot easily
understand how to use them,
adoption will suffer.
The Apigee Edge developer
portal addresses that need.
Via the portal, API
providers can publish
a catalog of API products.
API consumers, developers of
the apps that invoke the APIs,
can learn about the available
APIs and begin using them.
So let's see it working.
First I'll assume the
role of API provider.
Sign into apigee.com.
Click on this portals link.
Plus portal will
create a new portal.
Name it.
Clicking through, I
can manage that portal.
This page gives access to
the theme, the portal pages,
various settings, and assets
like images and so on.
But let's see what
the portal looks like.
We'll click on the live portal
link and see the sample.
This is what API consumer
developers would see.
Now, this is just the sample.
You'll want to
change your portal.
Let's flip back to
the administrative UI,
once again, assuming the
role of API publisher.
Let's make some quick changes,
first, the logo image, the hero
image, a custom diagram.
Here I've uploaded
only image assets.
You can, of course, add
assets of other types.
Now the theme--
I have full control over
the CSS for the site,
so you can brand it
any way you like.
I'll just paste my own
CSS in and publish that.
Some text for the homepage,
I'll publish that.
Text for the getting
started page--
and publish.
OK, let's see what we've got.
That looks pretty good.
Let's click around here.
We can see the getting started
page, a link to support.
Now, in your portal, you
can define the menu here
and the pages they open.
In this video, you
learned the basics
of API portals and the basics
for styling your portal
and adding your own content.
You can also publish
APIs to the portal.
We haven't done that yet.
That's a topic for
the next video.
Until then, keep it digital.
[MUSIC PLAYING]